sky I need you
to be the ant-man huh
Amy is a different kind of movie for
Marvel it's a much more intimate movie
and it features a hero who has some kind
of weird powers he can shrink down to
the size of an ant but it also increases
his speed and density and he can also
control ants hank pym who was the
original ant-man created what's called
the Pym particle which is really what
gives a man his power
one of the things I love about the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is to me it
mirrors what I loved as a kid in the
Marvel Comics world which is in the
Marvel comics there was this editorial
attitude and it was it was highly
comedic you know there was a there was a
lot of humor in all the comics even when
the stakes were real it's really fun to
be able to play with different tones and
having Paul Rudd at the center of this
you know playing Scott Lang is a huge
deal because as I said the ant-man
powers are kind of weird and what Rudd
brings to the movie is this sort of
self-effacing attitude you know he he's
gonna react to these things probably the
way you were I would you know he's
getting sucked into this world he had no
idea existed I think one of the fun
things about ant-man is there are little
Easter eggs cast throughout the movie
section toward the end of the movie
where Scott Lang has to make a journey
into what we call the quantum realm I
won't spoil what it is but while he's in
there he doesn't see it but if you're a
keen eyed audience member you might see
it whether it's a thing or a person
we're not sure but there's something in
there that that should be noted I would
also encourage the audience to stay to
the bitter end of the movie through the
end of the credits it might pay off in
some way that you possibly could derive
some enjoyment from it's a movie that
hopefully is is a really fun movie
you're gonna laugh plus you'll learn
about ants so that's a bonus one
question it's a toilet to change the
name
you